[Music]
creepy kid news that's like salt Oh
submitted by who's that creepy crawlers
yeah you're all good before your time
set know I remember Krueger college but
Eddie she couldn't afford as a kid
that's why I couldn't fart either
meaning submitted by I ain't no snitch
yeah yeah [ __ ] is good snitches get
stitches yeah that's what I was saying
that was your word to just get stitches
parents were asked about the creepiest
thing their kid ever said and they had
some pretty spooky or spot I love this
stupid kid my kid scares me I'm sock him
in the face that's the only thing I'm
like get the [ __ ] out of my house it's
like I get the [ __ ] out of my house
ghost just cuz he saw a ghost yeah yeah
if you want him what if you're raising a
baby Merlin and he's magical okay in
that situation then he could stay hey it
sounds like you're raising a baby magnet
to ghosts like I feel like that's just
this is bad having her you know if my
kid did say something creepy I wanted to
be those instances where the kid lived a
former life and he starts talking about
his life like in like 19 have you seen
those the ghost get that reincarnated
kids yeah we're not used to smoke me
cigar out in the porch just yeah [ __ ] it
like six years old sides one kid was
watching like a a German documentary of
like of Hitler speaking and he started
laughing at the jokes and stuff and the
parents are like what are you laughing
and he's like oh he told the funny joke
but it was all in German oh my god and
it turned out the kid was like a German
fighter pilot aeronaut German he was a
Russian fighter pilot in World War two
Kim crazy
yeah but then like the kids they
interview them years later and they
don't
for any of those memories so they go
through this phase of like the
reincarnation I think it's three to five
or something like around that age I
would try to like ask I think certain
things I mean I remember hearing about
that stuff like tell me about your wheel
maybe like do you remember anything or
like I don't know I was just try asking
him things I never got anything out of
him later saving maybe he wasn't the one
that was reincarnated but I mean she's
Brandi then he's not recycled yeah maybe
you saw he elevated from from dog energy
I think that animals are like being
punished I think there are people that
[ __ ] up yeah that's negative right
yeah I get Bob back is like you have to
be a cat now you can't talk I just wear
my cat that was a person like he looks
at me like - yeah I know it's okay see
I'm like I know this doesn't make sense
but our cats are way too similar to the
way we are so I'm like what if this is
somehow they are somehow like what's
reincarnated on the same the same
timeline yeah so anyway there's this
writer me was Mickey Kendall she tweeted
out people who interact with kids what
is the single weirdest / creepiest thing
a kid has ever said to you it's Saturday
night so why not creep yourself out and
then so is that a normal thing to do on
a Saturday or so why not yeah so there's
she got a ton of responses so here are
some of them this one from Alison she
says when my son was three he started
singing a polish nursery rhyme that my
husband's grandmother used to sing to
all the babies in the family she passed
away before my son was born
we don't speak or sing foolish that's
crazy that's cuz it's grandma yeah if
the grandma is the ghost sing it to the
kid I thought it was a reincarnated
Graham I think in the ghost
I was thinking about you this is cute
because I would want grandma goes to be
around me because that means she's
protecting me
my grandma's to beat my ass maybe not
your grandma oh my god she beat me so
much I know actually I didn't know I was
a released favorite grandkid I can see
why beat the living [ __ ] out of me thing
I so [ __ ] bad like her but anyways
yeah good memories no if I saw her
beating you up I'd beat her ass I got
you it's because you've conditioned to
feel like that means love yeah physical
violence equals lightweight did deserve
it however all of us deserved it but I
was the only one that got hit that was
the problem that's not you see what I'm
saying yeah so maybe you were her
favorite actually maybe my grandparents
never hit me man you so lucky dude they
look like my grandma beat me so bad once
my dad didn't let her see me for like a
whole month well you know what your
problem is David you don't repress your
memories I thought I told me my grandma
used to abuse the [ __ ] out of me
but I just have nothing but great
memories with her she said one time she
was on top of my back like riding a
horse and smacking me on top of my head
my god and I don't even remember that I
just remember cuz I remember all the
good stuff too but I remember the bad
things too like I just remember like I
remember you know that bamboo green
stick yeah she swung it so hard at me
she barely missed my eye and she got me
right across the face and I walked it up
right here that's love that's crazy yeah
that's why I didn't see her for a whole
month
if you're begging for hugs right now
you're not going to get it oh I'm not
that's how much that's how much I loved
her though only a mile so do remember
her when we would be in car rides and
I'd be really tired she would just tell
me to sleep on her lap and that she
would like stroke my smack you
she would like to do this that's like
one of the nicest memories I have maybe
that's what you like doing it yeah maybe
she's to always do that for me do you
know they did a test with dogs and so
they gave there was one group of dogs
they always gave positive reinforcement
to so whenever the dogs would come up
they'd give them a treat they'd be like
oh you're so nice to they only gave them
positive attention then other group of
dogs they only gave them negative
attention though like they'd come up and
they'd be like no that no and they
wouldn't give them treats and then the
third group of dogs they would mix it so
it'd be like sometimes you get positive
sometimes you get negative but it would
be for no reason it was just random the
dogs that got the mixed treatment we're
the most loyal the ones that were the
most excited to see the person they'd
never know what they're gonna get yeah
exactly but it's weird like that because
they were being getting mean to
something or else you get spoiled
exactly sometimes you beat them out of
nowhere last puppy but that's why you
are like yeah you're so that's why
you're a loyal person
thanks to your grandma just beating me
and kissing me at the same time I was
like I love her they were the most
excited to see their owners yeah you're
pretty low you didn't let me beat her up
yeah I'm Lawrence [ __ ] Mitch you still
make this ghetto ass macaroni and cheese
too with ground beef all down you know
that that craps box but instead she will
put ground beef in there two compounds
to love that [ __ ] grandma rest in peace
love you punch me in the face later
someone said you smell different when
you're awake huh that's like what a kid
oh I probably took my kid for sure smell
me my sweet [ __ ] I know I'm gonna
[ __ ] close the door you little creep
that's kind of cute but she was like you
strange Steve smells different when he's
awake maybe cuz having bad breath in the
morning exactly like you sweat and stuff
and you like got that pungent like you
know he smells different in the morning
and I love the way Steve smells like his
body aroma but he like showers bare like
a lot like he's like very clean hmm but
on in his sleep is when he like sweats
and like she smells different yeah the
next one says
was - we were walking above a creek and
stopped to look at it she stared at it
silently and then pointed and said I
died in there sure these are all
reincarnated kids yeah a lot of you
that's [ __ ] this other one says when
my daughter was two I found her under
the table with one of my husband's old
children's books turning pages as if she
were being read to I asked her what she
was doing she said reading with Grandma
my husband's mother died two years
before she was born it was her book oh
okay
so it's a mix of ghost grandma's and
like reincarnated grandpa where the
grandpa's hat yellow back in the day
grandpa's gonna do [ __ ] lazy yeah where
are the grand plaza represented I think
if you're getting punished as a human
you also come back as a grandpa no soul
yeah next one says walking with my
two-year-old in a cemetery bar by her
house she says mommy who is that man in
the red jacket by the stone house oh my
he pointed to a mausoleum there was no
one else in the cemetery he's waving at
me she was coming over to the top no
they're all - yeah a lot of these are -
oh my god so reticulated - they're good
kids
two-year-old niece can't say any
sentences I can't wait till a tiger
start saying that stuff I know there's
so many people visiting me at night
mother like that he's all like English
[ __ ] how cute I'm death the next one
says I was about two months pregnant
making grilled cheese sandwiches for my
nephew and I asked him if he wanted one
and he told me no he want a boy cheese
sandwich and the baby in my tummy can
have the girl cheese sandwich come to
find out months later I was having a
girl and as she was replies my
four-year-old cousin also came up to me
and sat on my lap and started laughing I
asked him what's funny he goes it's a
funny baby in your stomach I didn't even
tell anyone it was pregnant yet Oh
damn how come they're smarter than us
they're connected yeah there could a lot
of people in the comment they're
receptive to energy and stuff they're
saying that kids are more connected to
the University they're able to like
after my mom says can we lose it because
you have all this other stuff bogging
you down and like the world and like I
don't want [ __ ] dead people visiting
me as [ __ ] as [ __ ] annoying but what
if they're cool yeah a friend tell you
the lottery numbers but that's like
people just coming into your room
without even asking I want that [ __ ]
[ __ ] I'm showing like jacking off [ __ ] I
would stop jacking off with Michael
Jackson you seem really weird
hey just be like oh my bad just finish
baby's moon walks out wait would it be
five year old Michael or would it be
like 50 year old Michael cuz five year
old night Annie Michael
yeah there's a little different I want
that Michael I want the Michael that was
still black Danny Michael one two three
like the first phase of the transition
of Jackson found a bed the bad I'll take
sick Michael I don't care Karen fireman
because he knows so much more and he can
help me yeah he was about to come out
the Illuminati's planner and I want to
know what he was gonna say was that
there's some documentaries grabbable on
YouTube you could watch it basically he
was about to go on his tour but
magically he was given too much medicine
that made him die yeah but on his whole
this is it tour if you watch the movie
that he came up with it's there's so
much like we got to change the world
it's net and you think it's like this
PSA but there's there's a motive there
yeah and there's a recording of him
talking to a group of people saying that
like he's gonna reveal everything he's
gonna tell all their secrets
he's like wait for the tour
why was he speaking about it so publicly
I don't know because he knew it was
coming they want to come after him
because I think he wanted to get a lot
of people to be there but I'm tired of
this you know so many people found out
so yeah ghost Michael Jackson I'm all
for it yeah only Michael though I don't
care if Abraham Lincoln comes and
watches me jack off or something oh come
on guys later
maybe some other creepy things I'm
creeped out okay you're like creeped me
more yeah yeah last time I have here I
said the twins go through vegetarian
phases periodically last time twin B
says they should cut back on meat
because of the fingerprint I look
puzzled so twin a explains that people
who don't eat meat have less visible
fingerprints when B says not saying
we're gonna kill anybody
20 a says but if it comes to it twin B
says yeah it'll be easier 28 says one
less thing oh that's pretty nice
those kids need to be put down how did
they even find out well maybe they were
best friends in jail and if they pinky
promise like next life will be together
or they were like a Bonnie and Clyde
yeah mass murder a couple yeah and
that's kind of cute that's gonna keep it
really you better V they're not my kids
I don't gonna [ __ ] if these are your kid
oh no no they need it they need to go
they need to go what keeps talking about
murdering what age is this I don't know
they're shooting mentions they're all
like two and three it's like 18 that
sounds like my kids
[Music]